apparently the app shows dummy data that
was hard-coded into the XML file let's
make the actual weather data appear on
screen using the forecast adapter for
now we'll use the same layout for all
list items but we'll incorporate two
today XML layout in the next video
conceptually the forecast adapter
manages the logic so that for each row
in the cursor we create a corresponding
list item think back on the explanation
in Lesson one about the array adapter
except instead of the data source being
an array now the data source is a cursor
from the database the layout for the
list item is defined in the list item
forecast XML file for one row of the
cursor we're going to go through and
extract out the values we call it
binding the data to the views because we
take the value in each column and we set
it on to a different view for example
the high temperature value will be set
onto the high temperature textview
the low temperature value will be set on
to the low temperature textview for the
next row we bind the data in the same
way until we create a list item for each
row in the cursor currently our code
defines forecast adapter as extending
from the cursor adapter class if you
look at the documentation for cursor
adapter you'll notice that it's an
abstract class there are two abstract
methods that we need to override bind
view and new view the new view method
returns a new list item layout but it
has no data in it the bind view method
takes an existing list item layout and
updates it with the data from the cursor
in the forecast adapter class in the new
view method we inflate the list item
forecast XML layout then in the bind
view method we bind the data from the
cursor to the individual views for
example from the cursor we read out the
weather description then we have to go
through the view hierarchy to find the
text view that has ID list item forecast
text view once we find the text once we
once we find the textview and we can
update it with the right description
we've provided it just below of the bind
view method to get you started before we
left some to do is for you to handle
we've provided a gist of code for the
bind view method to help you get started
but we left some - dues in there for you
to do in the gist we also included some
helper methods and strings for day
formatting that's because in our current
implementation all the dates are
displayed in the same way in the
wireframe so we have a more friendly
date format such as today tomorrow
Wednesday Thursday etc here's the logic
for what the helper method does to get
the friendly date string if it's this
week it says today or tomorrow or the
day of the week if it's more than a week
out then we use the format Monday June
8th and so on
after you compile and run the app the
actual weather forecast data should now
be showing in the app and it's using a
more friendly date format check these
boxes when you're done